yale is one place and one university  that really makes sure you have the  ideal environment to do your job and i'm  not talking only about lab space or  classrooms or libraries  there is a whole cultural environment  that makes you feel  good to do your work and helps you be  more creative and be more productive too  so in the department that i'm now they  host a  similar series every week and  having the contact with  researchers from other parts of the us  and from other countries they present  really high quality  presentations  that i don't have that that contact so  easy in brazil i have been able to get  in touch with experts in my in the field  of my interest  this way when i go back to brazil i will  be able to apply knowledge and this  skills acquired to contribute to  research and training of physician  there